governor sissel act says the state
looking for ways to help small
businesses still being impacted from
coved 19. he held a small round table
talking about grant money and issues
businesses and business owners are
facing
joe mohler was there he gives us a look
at what was discussed
established 1979 we do weddings
a lot of weddings a lot of events
funerals
debbie montoya owns antique rose florist
and henderson
the business survived but it was not
easy awful
because we were shot in the front what
helped was a small state business grant
it helped us to put back savings that we
had to borrow from
to take care of operating costs around
9400 businesses and organizations
benefited from the pandemic emergency
technical support grant also known as
pets
as your governor i fought tirelessly
over the last year to increase funding
for this vital program
monday governor steve syslak along with
community leaders discuss the impacts of
the grant
i am extremely proud to report that we
have now approved
102 million dollars in pets grant
applications
and the governor says they're not done
helping small businesses around the
state they say over the next few months
they'll be meeting with business owners
to see
what else the state can do we still have
more work to do a few problems were
brought up
from more financial help to daycare
challenges so access to capital is
something that should be in my opinion
it's an investment in the business and
the issue of hiring a business owner
says people would rather stay on
unemployment than go back to work
governor sysolak says they will not be
getting rid of the extra benefits that
expire in september
there are some people that it might
prevent from going to work
do we understand that we totally
understand that but
you know one of the problems that exists
is that the minimum wage was held way
too low for way too long
the governor says they are working to
see how additional federal funding will
help in the near future
joe mohler 8 news now